a March for Trump was held in Maricopa
County near Phoenix Arizona last week
and if Maricopa sounds familiar that's
because it's the same County presided
over by the outrageous birth or Sheriff
Joe Arpaio and attendees range from
state and local elected officials to
white supremacists let's take a look at
some of the highlights here's one of our
montages all great footage from our
friends over at the real news
take a look it's America we don't want
you to really Christian country if you
don't like it here go to stereo go to
someplace else
I don't line up as a banner Etowah to
let it go back home where the home of
American admin and people coming in
easily I'll actually have another foot
maybe if you if you point it out maybe
because they're scared they don't want
to stand up for their life those people
it says white people standing up for us
to get us through the civil rights
movement and gives our civil rights it's
going to take black people and colored
people standing up for white we have
white people saying black lives matter
which was funded by George Soros yeah
right so there was also obviously a
heavily armed anonymous civilian militia
there I guess to protect the Trump
supporters from Mexicans and Muslims I
don't know it's not really a trump rally
without a heavily armed militia
naturally in full military uniforms
let's take a look at the next clip our
militias out there alive they're out
here boss during their time when they
could be working right now
nobody has respect our servicemen they
might not have government affiliated
with their little servicemen and they
still work at our press office to make
sure this country is a wall they might
not tell you later in that because
they're protecting their people
reinforce Arizona congressman Anthony
Kern at the rally chanting lock her up
lock her up we still need to pursue that
the former sheriff of nearby Pinal
County Paul babo a fervent opponent of
undocumented immigration spoke at the
rally and he dated an undocumented
immigrant man for six years and it's
been confirmed that he knew the man was
undocumented we talked about the story
when it broke and according to the
ex-boyfriend Bobo threatened to deport
him when they broke up in 2012 if he
told anyone about their relationship
the beau at the rally yelling about
so-called
illegals in this clip important any
legals
coming across this border more important
than that drug cartels that we continue
to fight that that Trump is going to put
the foot his foot on their neck all
right and Pat let's skip the next clip
and just show people as I described some
of the other comments here some of the
other nonsense that was going on here
some of the key quotes from attendees at
the rally John McCain is a secret
communist about pizza gate I think
there's a lot there definitely enough to
warrant an investigation quote I just
want to let them know that I can't wait
for the liberal genocide to begin that's
the way to make America great again and
a 13 year old Trump supporter quoted
saying Jews should go back to their
country what country that is I'm not
exactly sure of course
Donald Trump won more votes in Maricopa
County than in any other County in the
entire United States the Phoenix area by
far has the most hate crimes per capita
than any other locality in Arizona hate
crimes into the Phoenix area against
Hispanics black people Jews and gays
have all spiked since Donald Trump's
election they say everyone's
communists they call for genocide and
deporting Jews but they object when
they're called neo-nazis or Nazi types
or whatever they want to take out
Democrats and shut down liberal speech
but they're also the same people acting
claiming to be victims of political
correctness saying that Oh everybody
needs to be free to have a different
opinion everybody needs to be allowed to
speak freely at all times no exceptions
and they want to take out people who
have different opinions it's times like
these that I wish Hillary Clinton hadn't
backpedals on the entire basket of
deplorable comments there's a discussion
about this on our reddit discussion
forum I encourage you to check it out
david pakman.com slash our IDI vit
today's episode of the david pakman show
is made possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription in - I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like an an
eyeglass or the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
cost at including lenses and for every
pair sold they give a pair to someone in
need so to try the five pairs and
support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS